ça va être une
catastrophe vous êtes surprise non mais
moi je suis un peu inquiète vous
attendiez à ce que je vous fasse chanter
non absolument pas vous prenez un risque
tout le monde va tourner son poste et
bien on va essayer de retenir les gens
chez eux messieur le marteau 1 2 3
[Musique]
4 allezy
si j'avais un marteau je cognerai le
jour je cognerai la
nuit pour
tra et le soir pour la soupe
j'appellerai mon père ma mère mes frères
et mes
s bonhe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
derè merci
bravo vous VZ chanter un petit un un
petit land euh je vais vous dire deux
trois titres comme ça rapidement vous me
direz si vous en aimez un plus qu'un
autre je pensé Boubli ou Pau petite
fille riche riche bien vous vous en
souvenez ouais non je m'en souviens pas
parce que mais j'aime bien po c'est très
tendre très doux bon je vais vous la
chanter je vais vous la dédier tout
spécialement TR 4 toute seule sur cette
plage pauvre petite fille
riche toute seule si seule pauvre petite
fille
rich tu pleures parce que tu n'as pas le
droit d'épouser un pauvre garçon comme
moi pauvre petite fille
riche
voilà merci